they taught you and i never thought i'd
have to use this they teach you how to
kick someone off you if you're
if they're like trying to drag you down
oh well i'm going to save someone
if you're trying to save someone right
if i'm drowning you kill me with me
because some people right when they're
when they're when they think they're
drowning they panic and what they do is
that they push you down
yeah because they think i want to get up
yeah and you know it's not like a
selfish thing where they're like yeah
yeah i'm dying and you're dying with me
it's like
yeah literally it's like instincts kick
in for them and they think
so what you do is like aim for the head
so if they're trying to like grab on to
you
and push you down you grab them by the
arms and like
like so you so let's say you're equal
now in the water we're both on top of
the water heads
you grab them and like you go down under
the water and you kick them up
and kick them off you right right right
right so you push them away
and then you basically just grab them by
the face when you
i'm not sure i'm not kidding when you
save someone you're supposed to grab
them by the chin like this
and like pull them holy [ __ ] um or
you can there's some other ways but
that's the easiest because that way you
can kind of just do it like your own
pace you can kind of
there's other ways like you can you can
grab them but that that's really awkward
uh
it depends like how big they are and if
you like if it's like a child like
sometimes grabbing them by the face
might be a bit much
[ __ ] get over it
[Music]
like you don't really think about is
that you don't bring spare uniforms yeah
that's not really your thing so if you
if you go in um and you you save a kid
and it's still your shift you just go
right back to the chair
yeah yeah and you're soaking and you
know some people
they take the time like the first time i
did it i thought i i i have to go in
right away i have to save their life
right away yeah and i wouldn't take my
shoes off or anything yeah but then i
realized all the people who like
experienced they would just walk down
slowly they would just take off their
shoes
and socks because they knew they had
time and they knew like it's a pool they
know they're going to grab them right
away
so they're like i'm not getting my nike
air maxes where what the [ __ ] bro like
there's like a kid drowning in there
they sit down like this right they've
seen them like because if they're
flailing you've got plenty of time yeah
so they would just like
sit they'd like walk down really slowly
like this you know and then they'd be
like
okay take the watch off like this you
know like
and then they would then they would go
in yeah it was really funny i just
thought it was really bizarre but then
they i was like why did you do that
isn't that like bad they're like no no
they're not gonna drown yeah
they're not gonna drown i know the
average time it takes yeah
well there's a moment again the moment
if you're worried is if they don't come
back up that's when you have to like
immediately go in yeah
so that was all like that was fine and
like again this like never happened
this is only with little kids because
little kids are dumb i mean i make out
these stories to be a lot more exciting
than they are
in general the job was extremely boring
like it is
one of the hardest jobs to do just out
of sheer insanity like
you sit there for 30 minutes at a time
just watching people swim
yeah then you take a 20-minute break and
then you go back to it and this is like
for like six hours
just watching people swim and at first
it's such a weird thing to do because
i'm like
yo what if people get a problem with me
like staring at them while they're
swimming
you know like like because i'm like you
don't stare at people normally because
we gotta watch the pool right
is it weird that i'm looking at people
like there's parents watching me what if
they think i'm looking at their kid too
much
but i'm just making sure that they're
not drowning okay it's not weird right
like
these are the thoughts you have when
you're going insane sitting there for
six hours thinking like
is it weird is it weird that i'm looking
at everyone for like this long is it
this i'm going inside
like an existential crisis
i legitimately started like going insane
working there because i was like
you have to just think how long did you
do that for ah
god about just under a year and then i
went to
and then i moved away um but yeah i got
that job from doing a different job
which i talked about at different times
it's completely different yeah
it was really funny as well but like
lifeguarding in general is like super
boring but the pay was really good
because you have to get the
qualification
yeah and you have to be taught a lot of
stuff i mean yeah you're there to save
lives yeah yeah yeah and the course is
quite hard like and you have to redo it
every year
and so i i can't be a lifeguard now
because i haven't got i didn't renew it
all right
so uh but for the one year it was yeah i
mean it was it was it was fine i mean
the pay
the pay was insane like being 18 and
coming
and i feel like learning the basic first
aid skills is really [ __ ] important
yeah it was really helpful because i
i was never taught it we don't get
taught in the uk yeah yeah we don't get
too so i don't know how to do cpr
i mean they come in once and like push
the chest and blow
oh we we i didn't even get that i didn't
even get it really i thought it was
every year oh like during high school
i'll be [ __ ] yeah like i i do not
know how to do the [ __ ] heimlich
maneuver as well yeah yeah we just have
to learn like all the basics
um all the basics now because
it's gonna be real awkward if i'm gonna
be like hold on let me just bring up
this youtube tutorial for a second
all right wait wait wait i got i got on
sponsored it's sponsored
hold on hold on a second
a lot of aspects of the job were fun
yeah not many
like you i had to like clean as well
like clean all the
toilets and showers which was like i
mean i didn't know i was gonna do that
but
right glad you spent 400 bucks to clean
toilets
you know you're there and when you're
wrapping up and there's no one left in
the pool you just start cleaning because
that's
what you're supposed to do um but yeah
and then sometimes
uh i had to like because even though i
wasn't i wasn't teaching the kids but
for the kids who are like one year old
and they're learning how to swim they
had to be someone in the water
constantly with them all right right and
those kids just [ __ ] like don't let
go of you
and it's like no get off me little [ __ ]
it's like wrestlemania with like babies
it's like get off me
supposed to learn how to swim but the
moment they let go of the wall they're
like
and they've like they suddenly gained
the grip strength of like a grown man
it was just yeah i mean it was it was
just it was all right job really it was
just paid well but
the kids at the pool are scary just just
kids man kids [ __ ] suck
and if your kid can't swim teach them
how to swim